hi in this video we'll be talking about
the replication of RNA viruses from the
classification of the viruses we
understand that RNA viruses could be
either single-stranded or double
stranded in this particular video are we
talking about the replication process
and the assembly process of single
stranded RNA viruses inside the single
stranded classification of RNA viruses
there could be positive since RNA
viruses or negative sense RNA viruses a
positive fames RNA virus and negative
sense RNA virus use different strategy
to replicate inside the cell and to
assemble inside the cell so we would
understand the processes at the end of
this video so stay tuned till the end of
the video so let's talk about the
replication of positive sense RNA virus
first and then we talked about the
negative sense so the first step of the
viral entry is attachment of the viral
particle to a cellular receptor which is
displayed on the membrane surface now
the virus get adsorbed on this receptor
then the second step is penetration if
the virus is enveloped there is there is
no problem the angle of fuses with the
membrane but if the virus is not
enveloped it can also undergo receptor
mediated endocytosis shown like here and
inside the endosome the virus particles
especially the viral capsids
where the matrix protein all these
things get disassembled because of the
altered pH and the viral RNA gets out
into the cytosol now the enveloped virus
such as HIV and influenza virus they has
ease of the axis because they have
enveloped and it quickly fuse with the
membrane and that
that's allow the membrane entry very
easily nan in where the viruses has a
little bit difficulty but they also get
inside by receptor mediated endocytosis
now let's talk about what happens when
the virus is inside the cytoplasm and it
has released its genetic material into
the cytoplasm inside the cytoplasm as
it's a plus turned RNA virus its RNA is
treated like an mrna and it can be
directly read by the cellular host
ribosomes and it can be directly used to
synthesize the proteins so it is
randomly translated and it would create
viral matrix and capsid related proteins
other side these plus since RNA works
like a template and it's get to a
intermediate hybrid state which
ultimately gives rise to more plus ten
RNAs
now these extra plus strand RNA either
they could be used as a template for
producing more viral proteins or they
could be used to package into a viral
new virus right now all the when all
these things happen the packaging and
assembly happens in the Golgi apparatus
and the endoplasmic reticulum and via
the cell secretory pathway it gets out
from the cell and ready to infect
another cell and that's how positive
strand RNA virus replicates inside a
cell now let's talk about the
replication of the negative strand RNA
virus now the negative strand RNA virus
can also enter the cell just like the
positive strand RNA virus I I said the
envelope virus could directly fuse with
the cell membrane or it could also fuse
by receptor mediated endocytosis
now after that there is a problem
cause in the negatives in RNA virus the
RNA is not detected by the ribosome so
the ribosome would treat that as an
antisense RNA so it cannot translate
that it's not like mRNA so first step it
has to reverse transcribed to a positive
sense RNA such that the viral protein
can be produced so so host tribe assume
cannot detect it but there are viral
polymerizes which are carried by the
virus itself now the viral polymerase
would create more positive strand RNA
and as a result this positive strand RNA
now can be translated using the host
ribosome it can create viral matrix and
keep C capsid proteins and some of these
positive strand RNA would further work
as a scaffold to produce further
negative strand RNA which would serve as
a genetic material now after all this
process the Assembly of the viral matrix
protein and capsid would happen in the
ER and Golgi and following the cell
secretory pathway it would be released
from the cell and it is now ready to
infect another new cell which is not
infected before so I hope this was
helpful
and if you enjoyed this video you very
Week comes up don't forget to Like share
and subscribe and don't forget to
comment at the end of the video thank
you